tout le monde est conquis par ton album
et tout le monde dit que tu as fait un
travail exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
l'ageroute a réuni tout le monde même
ceux qui étaient un petit peu sceptique
sur maître gims ils disent vrai
franchement là on peut fermer notre
gueule et dire qu'il a fait un travail
ça fait plaisir que j'ai le rond retour
vraiment mais vraiment c'est ouvrir
respect complètement con mais pourquoi
mettre 40 d'un coup et pas faire
plusieurs albums c'est pas plus rentable
de faire plus ça c'est la bonne que
caron d'un coup pas mal pas mal c'est
bah non c'est une bonne question c'est
honnêtement j'avais peur de d'enlever le
tube je me suis dit ça ce jeu je vais
vouloir mettre sous la dent prochain
alors que c'est celui là le single c'est
je voulais vraiment pas me brider mises
d'accord face à audard quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai vu bravo à l'histoire pain est
allée fracasser alors qu'ils étaient
invités une heure à mener c'est nul
c'est pas bien fait dans les anciens de
dérision ça me dérange pas messieurs les
clashs et ça fait partie du jeu c'est
assez exposé tous les jours on est là la
télé etc
c'est normal mais là ça me fait ça ne
m'a pas fait rire oui la preuve qu'il
n'a pas lu ce nouveau texte surtout
parce que les textes octobre qui décrit
son passé elle l'a fait il arrive aussi
mais bon voilà lé o j'amène tapella
doors the boys ah ouais j'aime beaucoup
c'est à beaucoup l'émission baignez pas
est ce que tu vas y aller je sais pas
honnêtement j'aimerais moi je sais que
tu vas y aller ah ouais j'en sais rien
je peux pas je me rends pas envie ou pas
est-ce qu'il ya des discussions - n'ont
même pas pour le moment non il va être
limogé le dso il faut des discussions à
l'avenant non je demandais s'il faisait
acte officiellement de candidat n'en
veulent pas c'est à l'hôtel ses crocs
aux élections on dirait qu'elle féline
perdurer m j'ai rencontré johnny chan
mais j'avais malheureusement c'était
était fan s'est croisé way un vote
aurait aimé faire un duo avec lui mouais
c'était c'était prévu hawaïen
patiquement ross était prévu on en
parlait un peu avec des équipes
ouais les gens qui bossait sac ses clefs
de la peine toute cette histoire autour
d'eux oui bien sûr
d'archaos passera c'est joey starr on se
rejoint là dessus on n'est pas hyper
comme des oufs sur le gars il t'a des
critiques et ont notamment lors de la
mort de johnny leoni encore une nouvelle
tragique pour la culture française
aujourd'hui on aurait retrouvé maître
gims eux bien vivant chez lui il avait
tenté aussi une autre blague qu'elle est
l'appareil qui mesurent la musique de m
de merde le maître gims voilà ça même
pas sa voix en anglais c'est pas ça va
mon nom voilà donc toi tu t'en fous
raconte un père aimant tout le compte
même pas prêt voilà c'est bon c'est joey
il va 66 part qu on a eu beaucoup de
chance
ah oui c'est un art tient c'est un grand
artiste non vu que penser c'est un grand
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
coup le seul coach aime beaucoup aussi
j'aime beaucoup le fait c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup vraiment super mec ça c'est
grave c'est ta maman pour le monde on
voit la dark house avec ma mère j'avais
mais si c'est à moi je sais qu'elle est
sûre façon que j'ai un concert je sais
qu'elle est dans la salle que le fac
j'ai le trac à williamson ne pense qu'à
ça parfois tombé de faire des trucs
n'est pas que ma mère me vois faire
c'est ça ouais chez kabila dont je suis
pas fou mais ça elle nous regarde pas
car tu crois soit way sur le sud est
alors lembras le reconnaît c'est normal
c'est sa femme c'est la wii soit obligé
de dire d'art car tu as plein de gens
qui font partie de mon équilibre et une
autre personne que je vais te montrer
maintenant
alors ça c'est dazhou ses toiles à frère
tahar qu'aura sera est ce que t es ce
que tu es fier de lui de son succès
devrait beaucoup après préfère de serre
est vraiment ça fait longtemps qu'il est
là qui est qu'ils observent qui nous
suit depuis le début de la section il a
toujours été là il s'est vraiment il a
il a tout fait dans les règles a pas
sauté je lui ai donné des conseils ou
pas oui beaucoup beaucoup aimé n'ont
séduit que monde sommes donnés pour
cartonner tous les deux ça rohner il
freire qui vont arriver
[Applaudissements]